[Music]
in stunts gone wrong news all submitted
by Jill's personal [ __ ]
Oh Thank You assistant you're so lucky I
need one
oh thanks for not but things we're not
giving me that title that's my original
Oh sucks was that me yeah dig a [ __ ]
big girl I didn't know sad one ass that
woman was killed on the set of Deadpool
2 while filming a driving sequence oh my
god - [ __ ] Oh what was she driving
that's the one where she didn't have a
seatbelt on right really
no all right homie do you have a helmet
helmet cause she was on a motorcycle at
least she died doing what she loved that
did she what if she was like I already
liked this movie but it's paid it's a
paid gig I rather be on something like
Inception but [ __ ] it I'll do it that's
so sad I think she died doing what she
loved she died pursuing her passion yeah
most of people I know they really enjoy
stunts what doctors [ __ ] yeah so this
woman named joy SJ Harris to the or she
was a professional motorbike racer from
New York and they were filming at it
they were filming in Vancouver this was
actually her first movie that she was
working on oh no whoa her first and last
she never worked on any other movie
before yeah she was also the first
African American woman to be licensed in
the sport of professional road racing oh
yeah she was killed on set when she was
doing this stunt where she wasn't
wearing a helmet because the Kircher she
was portraying didn't need a helmet and
so apparently this was her last take was
the fifth take the first four were
successful but it's not clear whether or
not there were practice rounds or if
they were actually rolling so what was
happening was that she was supposed to
stop at the end of two flights of stairs
but then apparently it seemed like she
ended up hitting the throttle
sad and so sir witnesses are saying that
you can clearly tell like it was an
accident because she was just going out
of control she was going downstairs
apparently the way to describe it yeah
Wow
and so I'll stand here go downstairs
with a motorcycle
yeah but then I'm not sure exactly how
this thing looks because the photos from
the scene is in the street and so
apparently she hit the curb of a
sidewalk instead of going airborne into
like through a window pane oh sure I
didn't want was on the other side
there's just a building I'm not sure
exactly
I hate a sidewalk with the motorcycle
before and I flew really yeah what
happened I fell and then I my hand hit
that hit the sidewalk or the walking
area and I landed on that first and I
went down like that side this big scar
on my shoulder back we're not a big one
but then my my fingers are never the
same my phalanges I have a scar and my
fingers was your skin peeling off yeah
my skin peeled off here to where you
could see the white thank you anyway and
then the thing was I wasn't even in a
real like motorcycle I was in one of
those like little pocket bike
hahahaha I went from a really cool story
I know to a power wheel because my
friends uh like my co-workers wife she
wrote the cuff she wrote the little
pocket bike to my work to like bring
lunch or something it was pretty funny
cuz she's like was it a scooter be
honest it was like those cute little
motorcycles like a small sized one so so
she looked like a big gorilla on a
motorcycle but she's also like pretty
strong woman like not fat she's like
strong and then she she worked at the
docks oh yeah
okay so yeah so she brought that on all
the ocean I want to ride it
she's like go ahead they failed to tell
me that they're working on the bike
still it's a bike in progress and it
takes a long time for the brakes to like
react oh oh maybe they didn't like you
very much
so that I went out and in a car was
coming I was like holy [ __ ]
and in the I was like what the [ __ ] man
the brakes aren't like hitting like it's
taking forever they like stop so then it
just I just hit the side of the sidewalk
because I couldn't turn it right and
then I just flipped it and fell that was
so funny in my head
hello over the pocket bike yeah those
are the ones are your knees are sticking
out like this far yes
yeah well luckily you're okay yeah
how does she die then she gets ran into
a wall she went through a window but
though I mean did the glass cutter is
going through a window I'm gonna kill
you well she doesn't have a helmet on
right yes she didn't have a helmet new
head first and it hit the window
yeah they don't describe exactly like at
what happens
they just say that she died from her
injuries and they are even saying that
when rescuers went on scene that they
were there for 45 minutes and then they
after loading the victim they drove they
drove off without the siren so that's
like assuming she died immediately hi
guys this is joy for peace joy just so
sad
Kobe my oh thanks huh we guys are here
photos of the scene we went through this
this window that's really nice is on the
from Dulles not a give her privacy yeah
I look like some heavy glass [ __ ] yeah
that bikes all [ __ ] up
oh it's scooping up blood bloody glass
oh [ __ ] I want to be felt like [ __ ] like
Dan we had it for other time I know it's
not confirmed if it was better not but
oh yanan Ryan Reynolds ended up posting
this today we tragically lost a member
of our crew or filming Deadpool we're
heartbroken shocked and devastated but
recognize nothing can come close to the
grief and in explicable pain her family
and loved ones must feel in this moment
my heart pours out to them along with
each and every person she touched in
this world those Ryan Reynolds statement
in a situation like this I wonder if
they stopped tell me I hope so because
the studios for them it's a machine
right and then they got 110 is money
two dollars into a project I don't know
if
they wouldn't even stop for something
like this well they might call it off
for the rest of the day right because if
yeah I wasn't they can't need a stunt
person that can finish the same or do it
oh man I've been crazy magic filling in
her shoes like but it comes with the
territory like people that get into
stunts and all that stuff no like you
can't go ending that injury and things
like that
can't happen like you know Yoshi when he
was a part of the Waterworld show and
Universal Studios the first day of the
show she didn't close his mouth like
you're supposed to close your mouth when
you take a huge die and then he messed
up and so she had his mouth open and the
impact of this this huge jump even
though you're jumping into water like it
feeling like that and he shattered his
mouth yeah and that's just from a show
at a theme park yeah but yeah something
was not bad for the rest of that day
because it happened like in the morning
the [ __ ] people go through to make us go
Wow for like a second is like pretty
crazy though if you think about it yeah
it's even crazier too then we start
critiquing the film like oh that was CGI
you know but so then because they're
trying to stop those comments then they
put the real people in it and it's like
look like they risk their lively crazy
we were watching this circus show in
Vegas we're watching all in particular
and you see people like diving off of
like 4050 feet and it's just people are
being catapulted into the air like three
seconds of hang time and I'm just like
national it's crazy so I started looking
at other but who can jump and die like
this and they hire a lot of former
Olympian divers and swimmers now and
there's been deaths on talk shows dude
yes that recently happened in I think it
was caught was it College not about four
or five years ago well that's still
pretty close maybe even three years but
it was someone who was on the up top and
they're you know they have the cables on
them doing their little circus act and
the the chicks fell like 40 feet or
something and they
stop the show for months Wow do you
think the show like went on so the
audience didn't know that someone just
died I think they knew actually I don't
know because they always have those open
stages where they just fall under - all
right and there's a trampoline at the
bottom so this was also the first stunt
person or performer killed in Vancouver
in over 20 years cuz I cuz it'll film
[ __ ] that they never filmin think that's
like say this is the first person to die
from making a film in the Galapagos
Island no I'm sure this film that
Cooper's is the second Hollywood though
yeah yeah this was such a Hollywood I
just wanted to talk [ __ ] to Canada why
was I laughing because we have so many
fans there I just want to give them some
recognition and find my clacking [ __ ]
yeah they use Vancouver the double New
York and double la Vancouver yeah I
think they use it to double Gotham
sometimes the - in a second Hollywood
hotspot I want to go to Vancouver and I
want to go to Montreal Montreal because
we just went to France well you know
it's like the France of America where
they speak friend America and Logan
America North America it is America but
it doesn't do and it doesn't resemble
anything else of French they speak that
that's it you've on your lens and get a
little bit of it not to dirty over
they're not kidding I want to go there
too but then I even hear that like
French people don't recognize Canadian
French oh and you're like Russia it's
not actual French not like all day
that's like the guy we met in France me
Christina were having lunch and the
people next to us they're speaking
French and English and you're saying how
he visited America and San Francisco and
he was like you know I don't know how to
say this but San Francisco you know is a
you know I don't know how to put this
but like try to copy the French you know
and he said in a bad way where it's like
the America trying to copy us because
the city looks like France with the
buildings all historical it's all tight
spaces yeah it was kind of like pitting
the Americans on that part and I was
like damn DS what a loser get nothing
but
it's building role like that did you
invent that [ __ ] like are you a Jew
building very invested in that I'm
pretty sure a lot of buildings in
America are inspired by European nations
you know it's they are white people
right they're going to be inspired by
that [ __ ] and they're going to bring it
back that was all like you stole France
like you expect America to be like
[ __ ] adobe Hut's all over the planet
the original [ __ ] I hope you guys
enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]